I'm never on defense I'll bail I'll bail
every when I when I was dating if I saw
anything that wasn't can if I did it so
I hate negativity it's why we have a
great culture if I did a girl that I
realized very quickly like she liked the
like it was intriguing to have conflict
I literally bailed immediate out forever
I just I have no effort for defense I'm
trying to win every game for 77 to 433
and I'm talking about baseball you know
what I mean like its purest but you know
what I mean but but baseball where
there's lower scoring that's why that's
the analogy [ __ ] soccer like I'm
trying to I'm trying to I'm trying to
score so many points that I'm not
worried about the casualties ramen Union
though this more because you've been at
Vayner so much like like I never care
about the failures at Boehner I love
when people's come in to me like listen
I gotta talk to you about this problem
it's really gonna undermine us I'm like
are you a [ __ ] idiot how the [ __ ] do
you think we got here if you want me to
play your micro game I'm gonna look like
everybody else so I'm always on the
offense always macro and always very
aware of what I want to happen